okay let's go next to our caller from
the eight three two area code caller
from eight three two who's there yeah my
name is Brian I'm from Houston and I
really love your show just want to let
you know thank you also my question is
given what we know about the 2016
primaries where the Clinton Foundation
and the DNC there was a lot of
corruption going on behind the behind
the scenes essentially the Clinton
Foundation was you know had a had the
DNC a like will the DNC was basically
sorry to be confusing the DNC was
basically an arm of the Clinton
Foundation given what we know well what
do you found out there what yeah so I
agree with you that the DNC basically
pre-selected and supported Hillary
Clinton but what do you mean the DNC was
an arm of the Clinton Foundation
well basically Kyle did a segment over
this over on secular talk and basically
during the the 2012 election
the DNC used up all his funds and was in
debt so there was a backroom deal with
debbie Wasserman Schultz and a Clinton
Foundation where the Clinton Foundation
essentially bailed them out in return
for some privileges and that's what I
mean by essentially it was an arm of the
Clinton Foundation okay I'm not but
that's okay yeah I mean you should
definitely look at it Kyle did a segment
over it um basically my question is how
do we know that the 2020 primaries won't
have a similar outcome given that
Hillary's rerun is still up in the air
we don't according to recent reports we
don't I mean whether or not Hillary
Clinton runs won't even change it no
matter what
the DNC may once again have its finger
on the scales even if they are more
heavily restricted from acting in a more
public manner to support a candidate
it's very possible that in in more
private ways they would support
candidate so I share your concern I'm
extremely concerned about what role the
DNC is going to have in the 2020 primary
there have been some changes made in
terms of the super delegate stuff and a
few other things have changed which
should improve the circumstances
somewhat but I absolutely fear your
concern yeah I mean that's pretty much
that's pretty much my only question
because you know the press the president
the twenty the twenty twenty election is
just around the corner and I know that
there's gonna be a lot of pushback with
the DNC and progressive yeah I mean the
the remedy for this like with everything
else is everybody has to vote right so
the DNC putting its finger on the scales
matters more the fewer people vote the
more people votes the influence of the
DNC to override the will of the people
is diminished so when it comes to
getting Trump out is voter turnout when
it comes to having voters actually be
fully in control of who the nominee is
it comes to people voting that's the
solution you know that's what
everybody's got a vote yeah all right
thank you for the call great to hear
from you appreciate it